hey everybody welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment today is the return
of our vs. series in this vs. series we
take two of our panelists with opposing
views and we have them fight out a
specific topic right here on the show
today's topic can you get I don't know I
don't know
we've got Scarlet Spider versus when who
is the better alternate version of
spider-man we'll get into specifics on
that in a minute but first well we want
you to make sure you like to Facebook
page and that's at Facebook comics /
awesome comics show talking about spider
clan we'll get into that later more
spider when she loves it we love it good
stuff okay and then new videos every
Thursday like she said thank you for
taking part in our first Facebook live
Q&A video this past Saturday we hope to
do more of those in the future so let's
get to our panelists first here we've
got Ayanna way beyond the side of the
table today
I'm sure yeah it's good right
yeah this dude is different I feel I've
been there twice now yeah yeah with
great power comes great responsibility
power first gonna do Ayanna's character
history on spider-gwen
all right take it away Gwen Stacy Spider
Woman debuted in edge of spider-verse
number two in September 2004
as part of a spider-verse comic book
storyline for a warm reception and
popular design led to our own series
spider-gwen in 2015 we're in this earth
65 alternate universe when Stacy was
bitten by the radioactive spider
instead of Peter Parker and becomes
Spider Woman Walter go ahead with your
character history on Scarlet Spider Ben
Riley is the first fully successful
clone of Peter Parker created by his
nemesis professor miles Warren aka the
jackal his first appearance was in the
amazing spider-man number 149 in October
of 1975 but it's much more famous upon
his return in the infamous Clone Saga
Jiri debuted with the name Ben Riley a
combination of Uncle Ben and Aunt May's
maiden name in spider-man number 51 back
in October of 1994 Ben's rich character
history includes leaving New York after
finding out he was a clone of Peter
after many adventures on the road and
years away from his home then caught
when the Aunt May was in the hospital
with a serious illness he then returned
to the buyer side his homecoming
eventually resulted and then taking up
the Scarlet Spider identity and even
later becoming spider-man for a time
when Peter retired after his wife Mary
Jane Watson became pregnant he was
killed in a battle with the Green Goblin
but remains a popular cult figure of who
from time to time resurfaces in some
form or another in various comics since
he met his end in the nineties all right
with further ado let's get to question
number one that is if they were to fight
each other who would win Ayana ticket
away all right so spider-gwen in her
universe gets is like notorious for
having to deal with lame villains so
she's beating the vulture but she has to
go up against people like koala
commander so although she does a great
job keeping her universe thanks it's
very difficult to judge how she stands
up against regular heroes but she's only
given terrible terrible terrible
villains device it's very hard
however in spider-gwen annual number one
she does end up teaming up with she-hulk
to wrestle after they go against each
other in a wrestling match luchador
style
and the announcer announces that maybe
she Hulk has met her match so she's very
very strong she's also a very good
teammate
she's very strong standalone character
but a very good teammate in the spider
army which she is a part of and I don't
know I think on tons alone ok what about
like her actual fighting style though
how does she fight usually like so her
powers were going ahead into powers then
she has nearly identical powers to
spider-man she is this earth 65
universes version of spider-man
so Peter Parker never becomes spider-man
when Stacy has actually been by the
spider Peter Parker actually ends up
becoming the lizard and dies so Peter
Parker ends up kind of becoming her
Uncle Ben and reason to continue as a
superhero giving her the drive to do
that um so she has the same powers she's
able to stick and climb on wall she has
a spidey sense for danger she's able to
lift 10 tons
she has enhanced speed endurance agility
she has expert detecting skills and
analytical thinking obviously she also
has good detective skills because her
father is detective and she's a
freestyle fighter so we're sort of in
her part of her like origin story still
it's not quite fleshed out of who she is
as a character still which makes for
very interesting Dorit storytelling
very difficult for figuring out how she
would hold up one on one so it's cool
but she's a very freestyle fighter so
she's not as as trained yet I would say
okay fluid in battle right right well
okay so first of all there's no way Ben
Riley would fight any version of
Wednesday's Peter Parker basically so I
mean he would never fight there'd be too
many emotional going on there's no way
but if they were to actually fight Ben
is much more experienced with his powers
and then Gwen Stacy is at this point
spider-woman in this current run is
still very young and she's still high
schoolers right after college
she's College okay so she's still like I
knew like early 20s at the oldest right
now
Ben has all the memories of spider-man
up until his cloning and
you know that that whole other life he
made for himself getting different
experiences and stuff and you learn new
things that Slayer might never
experience so yeah it's all of Peter
Parker with these different experiences
that he he went on the road and and got
to take part in himself so he's about
like in his early 30s or late 20s I
think in the in the main run that he
appeared in so yeah he knows what to do
in high-pressure situations he can he
like Peter Parker he can analyze the
situation figure things out he's very
used to his powers were again
spider-gwen isn't quite she just got her
powers like even the comic like a year
ago or something right so she's still
very inexperienced yeah he also enjoys
fighting more than Peter Parker does
which is an interesting tidbit Ben Riley
enjoys fighting more I that might be
from his years on the road just sort of
rolling it out yeah so he enjoys
fighting more he's also extremely smart
he's got these Peters clone so he has
the genius level scientific intellect so
I think he's smarter than Glenn and he
beats her just about in every way you
know it's not much of an argument
there's a wild card that she might win
you never know but I just think it's
it's kind of a mismatch at this point
until she gets a little older and more
experienced okay so here's the thing
though what's the multiverse wristwatch
what does Gwen is able to travel from
the multiverse from multiple to multiple
in any area at all because of a
wristwatch so she could zip out be back
right behind you so it's basically yes
but teleport to the different multiples
she teleports the vias space and time so
it's she's not she's not she does she's
not linear in where she was that time no
it's not time okay so there would be
amazing though because that I was just
thinking of like doctor spider-gwen
okay I think that the spider sense would
probably kick in before she can really
do any damage with that well how far
does the spider sense go does it go
between the motors she appears behind
absurdly at least you know catch it so
she has to be super precise I'm not
precise that watches
if she appears like right behind him is
already like swinging for a punch or
something maybe she can get the jump on
yeah I mean it would be an interesting
fight okay let's go on a question - who
uses their spider abilities like the
best or the most who really like holds
it down with just their spider abilities
okay so as I said before he's a Chloe
Peter Parker so he has all of Peters
knowledge and everything he's you know
he has all the experience that Peter has
up until the point was cloned so he has
all that behind him but Ben also
invented ways of using his abilities
that Peter never even thought of
invented impact webbing
these are fired out as a miniature web
palette that exploded on impact and
casing a target within a web cocoon and
rendering him or her virtually
immobilize those are small
diamond-shaped darts Cody and a
paralyzing chemical agent to
incapacitate opponents he also invented
mini dot tracers that are shaped like
miniature frisbees and are much smaller
and lighter than Peters spider tracers
they're 1/4 of the size which are much
faster when fired from the web shooters
he's also a bit darker with his powers
and more stealthy there's a couple
stories with him on the road that he
cuts or to use his powers like that man
he's like in a house and shadows and
comes out it's just more mysterious in
the way he flights people it's really
cool it's kind of like a scary character
sometimes all that and like I said he
you know he has Peters intellect and
spider-man who obviously the Peter
Parker version of spider-man uses his
powers to the is the full potential that
he possibly can and then has that within
him so yeah Ben knows how to use his
powers pretty well okay so here spider
powers obviously are the same as spider
same with same web shooters um they
actually got they were created by Janet
Van Dyne who was in the 6565 Universe
okay and so she made her new ones and
they filter moisture from the air that
can help create like the adhesiveness
tooth on so she swings
she's them as ropes as gloves they they
don't require a refill as long as
there's moisture present so she like
they don't run out as long as there's
moisture present she's good to go right
in the middle of a bear
just flip nothing that's we've seen it
before so well unless you're able to
suck the moisture out of so the world
there's still like a thing that could
happen there but yep there's no refills
so if they're going on endurance alone
maybe but yes so she's she's basically
the the same because she's this
universes version so she's able to lift
she's able to climb she uses it to fight
every night sometimes at the detriment
of her band the mary-jane and they have
the face of tiger song is real now oh
yeah couple bars no does either of them
use their powers like when they're not
in Spiderman gear spider-gwen gear like
they use it a lot in their personal life
yeah then I mean when he went on the
road he didn't want to be you want
anything to do with spider-man or being
a vigilante or anything like that so he
kind of just used his powers like one of
the the most important things about Ben
when he went on the road was that yeah
you didn't want to have anything to
inspire man so he basically cast his
powers aside I didn't really use them
except when he's like really pushed so
like there's a there's a little story
where he here over here someone's gonna
rob a house or something at a certain
time and that's where that him coming
out of the shadows thing comes in and
stuff so he does use it a lot out of
costume because at that point he really
didn't care he didn't want to be
spider-man anymore at that point so he
did want anything to do with Peter
Parker he wanted to create a completely
new life for himself so he does use his
powers you know when he's really pushed
when there's something in front of them
he can't turn down that responsibilities
so if whether he's in tirana costume he
uses his powers I mean tries to conceal
his face a little bit there's a couple
things we he's got a bandana also can I
say in the main run Ben Riley has the
sweetest mullet Nightwing no it's better
than nightmares even Kyle even Kyle
Reiner's I know Ben Riley did it was a
nice flowing crown with some nice five
o'clock shadow like I look so gruff and
he was riding a motorcycle okay hair
alone then spider-man automatically very
different it's more modern it's like I'm
I feel like a modern like nimble in here
yeah but no she mostly doesn't use it in
her everyday like she's still in that
like zone of her career to where she's
still trying to hide who she is her dad
knows that she's spider-gwen though that
came up but in the most recent issue
number 11 she basically is like forced
to step up with her responsibilities and
like kind of comes out just busting
through a wall so yeah so she she'll be
starting to use them out of costume it
looks like right
so no cliche final question I like this
one the most
who is the more interesting character
overall who's the most interesting read
I want to start I will okay so I think
Ben is one of the most interesting
characters in all the MCU
I think he's super under a daemon yeah I
think he's extremely underrated I love
Ben Riley he is Peter Parker but if all
this crazies clone stuff happened to him
I mean imagine that you think you're a
person your whole life and then all of a
sudden you realize that you're not the
person you thought you were how do you
reconcile that Ben gets lost for a while
he goes on the road he doesn't really
have an identity doesn't know who he is
and him coming back to New York and
everything is what sort of made his
circle complete I mean yeah the fact
that he's not a stereotypical evil clone
that's a great idea
I love the idea of a guy being cloned I
think we talked about this in the in the
Batman top-10 about the missile console
sort of retaining morality if he's
really a clone or a copy of someone and
yeah Ben is perfect for that he shares
Peters values and he puts them to the
test in different ways because Ben is
you know been uh been involved in some
bad situations when he was away from New
York for those years but he's a really
tragic character I think and this is
important because everything he thought
like I said was ripped away from him he
thought he was was ripped away from him
and he had to rebuild his life from the
ground up even more tragic because he
eventually returned to being spider-man
after all those years he was accepted as
a brother by Peter and a member of the
Parker family he came all the way back
and after regaining all that he dies
sacrificing himself to save Peter after
all of that just when he regained some
semblance of what he lost he dies saving
the original Peter Parker the years on
the road also made him a more gruff
character he really became a different
person and a different character than
Peter after those experiences and when
all was said and done so without a doubt
I think he's a more interesting
character than well spider-man is
definitely the more interesting
character right off the bat she's a
drummer for the Mary Jane's which is
awesome she has the multiverse
wristwatch she can travel through
dimensions there's a whole series of the
Spiderman like traveling through the
multiverse with silk
and Jessica drew spider-woman we've
talked about it on the show before
actually where they have adventures
because of the multi multiverse
wristwatch which is awesome
her design first off is fantastic that
that helped with her characters
popularity in general and it helps that
she stands out completely from silk and
Jessica drew spider woman and even holds
her own as a female variant of
spider-man she's not just like okay we
technically made Peter a girl Patricia
or something she holds her own as a
character and in some of the lists of
the best alternate spider-man that you
can find online news Arama
ranked Ben Riley at number six and
spider-gwen at number seven however
Screen Rant ranked her at number two and
Ben at number eight o comics Alliance no
Ben sorry but spider run was number two
again and then comic-book comm ranks
we're going as number four and thanks to
spider Glen we now have characters like
Gwen pool and Wenham no there's not
enough of it so I think she is just a
really really interesting character we
get to see an origin story for
spider-man that's something we haven't
seen we get to see it through the eyes
of a female which is interesting but
also it's not just a copy it's not like
a photocopy we're not getting the same
stuff we get to see a really completely
different person having to go through
similar things and becoming like a
completely completely different person
and yet such a similar person in general
becoming a superhero so we both sound
very interesting I'd love to see Ben
come back and being I was gonna say bro
yeah there's there's a clone conspiracy
as there's an arc that's coming out I
think next month called the clone
conspiracy that's bringing back the
jackal and the main continuity with
spider-man and they're already bring
back other characters please please
bring back Ben Riley please Dan
if anyone please share
with Dan Slott I don't know if he's
gonna see this or not probably not but
Dan bring back Dan Riley for the love of
God man you've been teasing it for years
swinging back I'm sorry please bring him
back please I want them back not the
main continuity Ben well I'm not
interested in going pool but Quentin
seems just so awful I'd like to actually
see that it's like a pink Cynthia or
something that would be so funny is in
being upset all right that was awesome
good good banter between you okay so
let's go to the pics a week oh um go
pick up firefighter Gwen and you
wouldn't want it for many many reasons
as I bend it and ruin it forever but for
one of the reasons just right off the
top of my head I showed you guys this
earlier um the Trump MODOK hilarious
that's so hilarious the image of just
Trump as MODOK with this tiny little
hand anyways anyways it's amazing
also there's definitely in the like
luchador singing like right at the
beginning there's freaking laughing at
and Hercules Mulligan
yeah yeah yeah yeah what amazing and
then there's also Captain America
holding a hot sauce back in here that's
amazing hot sauce hot sauce bet the acid
and then the spider grin like penguin oh
there's no dark there you go
oh hey oh hey oh yeah this is this is an
amazing issue we got spider Quinn
penguin it's just a really fun
compilation about very some stories
she's super funny yeah yeah what's your
pick of the week okay so I have a couple
so there's been a over that four years
they've been releasing the entire Ben
Riley run called the complete Clone Saga
epic which also turned into the complete
Ben Riley epic it's 11 giant volumes
like this
and I'm still making my way through them
I'm only on the sixth volume so it's a
long way to read but you are defining um
no you can put them on on Amazon most of
them I mean there's like one I think
vying for is a little bit difficult to
find but you get fine to use one on
Amazon or something like that but yeah
it's really cool because you get to see
every single book that he was ever
really in since the nineties and I'm
reading through it right now and I could
see why people kind of didn't like some
things about Ben Riley about the whole
Clone Saga thing because it went on for
so long but the main idea it's still
really cool so I have that also the the
Clone Saga they went back and did it Tom
DeFalco went back and redid the Clone
Saga and just six issues and they call
it the real Clone Saga with a lot of
different things happening so these are
really cool it's a more streamlined
version of them so thanks for spending
out the blind and ahead that's that's
Wednesday Duane pool or spider-gwen
that's Wednesday see what spider-gwen is
it's actually it is Gwen Stacy the other
ones aren't going right there's a coin
in there but anyway yeah that's if
you're looking for a more condensed
version of that storyline check out
these six issues they're a trade back
trade paperback form right now so go and
check those out also just want to
mention really quick these are the first
complicated lot at a accomplished shop
when I was like yeah so these are these
are man Ben Riley I've been with him
since the beginning that's what I wanted
to mention thank you very much guys it
was really enlightening on those two
awesome characters hopefully you guys
want to read a little bit more then let
us know who you think won this argument
this little verses here
who's the cooler character who is cooler
even still as an alternate spider-man
all right now be sure to tune in next
week we'll be talking about our favorite
comic book writers and artists we had a
special awesome guest that he's he's
gonna be here so we check that out and
it it's great episode
can't we talk about that one so for
social media we find you guys well you
could find me at awesome underscore
Walter on Twitter that's where I'm at
I'm on Twitter Facebook also don't
forget to check out
our Facebook where this Thursday I will
be talking about spider-gwen on ultimate
spider-man who's appearing in this
week's episode it was up Saturday the
17th once this episode's up so we'll
talk about the return to the
spider-verse part 4 so I'm excited to
see her on there and see boys acting and
stuff we'll see all right and you can
find me on Facebook calm / awesome
formal yourself from everybody here I'm
Brian Porter thank you for watching and
we'll see you on the next page
you